♪ ♪
>> THIS IS A VERY SIMPLE
STRAIGHTFORWARD ACT.
THE PRESIDENT BROKE THE LAW.
>> I BELIEVE IT WAS
INAPPROPRIATE.
I DO NOT BELIEVE IT WAS
IMPEACHABLE.
>> WHAT HAPPENED WAS WITHOUT
QUESTION IN MY MIND AS SOMEONE
WHO SAT IN THOSE ROOMS AND
LISTENED TO THESE WITNESSES,
WHICH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO, WAS
EXTORTION.
>> WE DON'T HAVE ANYONE FROM OUR
SIDE TO TELL OUR SIDE OF THE
STORY.
THIS IS GOING TO BE MORE OF THE
SAME AS LAST WEEK.
WE DON'T EXPECT ANYTHING
DIFFERENT.
>> Bret: WEDNESDAY, IT ALL
STARTS IN FRONT OF THE VIEWERS
PUBLIC HEARINGS UP ON
CAPITOL HILL.
THEY WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THEIR
OWN WITNESSES COME UP AND
TESTIFY.
THEY INCLUDE A LONG LIST.
HUNTER BIDEN, DEVON ARCHER, A
FUNDER BOARD MEMBER, TIM
MORRISON, DAVID HALE, AND
ALEXANDER TOLUCA,
A FORMER STAFFER.
THEY LIKELY WON'T GET ANY OF
THOSE.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL.
MAIN STREET PANELIST FOR THE
WALL STREET JR.
JR. JOURNAL.
OKAY, BILL.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT?
>> MY GUESS IS THESE WITNESSES
WILL BE CREDIBLE.
I THINK THEY'LL HAVE GOOD
RESUMES.
I THINK THEY'LL MAKE A VERY GOOD
IMPRESSION.
I THINK FOR THE COMPLETE STORY,
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO WATCH
CAREFULLY FOR THE
CROSS-EXAMINATION.
I SPOKE WITH HOUSE REPUBLICAN
LATE TODAY.
VERY CLOSE TO THE PROCESS.
HE DESCRIBED THE SITUATION.
HE WILL DEVELOP A "STORY LINE"
IN HIS OPENING STATEMENTS.
HE WILL MAKE CLAIMS OF ABUSE OF
POWER AND CLAIMS OF OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE.
WHEN THE CROSS-EXAMINATION TAKES
PLACE, HE DESCRIBED FIVE AREAS
THAT REPUBLICANS WILL CENTER ON.
A LOT OF THE INFORMATION THEY
BELIEVE WILL EMPHASIZE WAS THE
PRESIDENT'S REQUEST CONSISTENT
WITH U.S. LAW REGARDING
CORRUPTION AS IT REGARDS DOMINIC
RELATES TO UKRAINE?
THE HUNTER-BIDEN CONNECTION.
WAS IT ILLEGAL?
IF NOT, SHOULD IT BE?
THEY TESTIFY ON FRIDAY.
THE FIFTH 20 MADE WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
WE GAVE UKRAINE MORE EQUIPMENT
TO DEFEND ITSELF AGAINST RUSSIA
AND VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> Bret: THAT'S REALLY
INTERESTING.
HE PRODDED DOMINIC PROVIDED THE
PRESIDENT A LOT OF INFORMATION.
BARRY, THIS IS THE DEMOCRAT'S
CHANCE TO AFFECT PUBLIC OPINION.
>> RIGHT.
TO ME, WHAT'S FASCINATING IS
THAT THE REPUBLICAN ARGUMENT HAS
MOVED SIGNIFICANTLY THE LONGER
THAT THIS HAS GONE ON.
IT STARTED OFF AS READ THE
TRANSCRIPT.
YOU JUST HAVE TO READ THE
IT'S GOING TO BE CLEAR THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS IN THE RIGHT.
WELL, EVERYONE READ THE
TRANSCRIPT.
THEN, THE ARGUMENT BECAME THAT
IT'S NOT ACTUALLY IMPEACHABLE.
IT'S APPALLING, BUT IT'S NOT
IMPEACHABLE.
I THINK STARTING WEDNESDAY,
WE'LL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HEAR FROM ALL OF THESE CREDIBLE
PEOPLE.
THE QUESTION IS JOHN BOLTON IS
CALLING THIS THING A DRUG DEAL.
JOHN BOLTON ALSO PART OF THE
DEEP STATE?
A NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO AREN'T
QUITE --
>> Bret: WE WON'T HEAR FROM
JOHN BOLTON BEFORE ALL OF THE
SCHOOL'S FORWARD, WHICH IS
INTERESTING.
>> Bari: BUT THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE REQUIRED FOR REPUBLICANS
TO MAKE THE CASE THAT TRUMP IS
IN THE RIGHT, IT JUST DOESN'T
PASS THE SNIFF TEST TO ME.
>> Bret: HE STILL IS TWEETING.
HE MUST TESTIFY ALONG WITH
SCHIFF AND OTHERS.
HE IS HOPING THAT THE TRANSCRIPT
STILL STANDS ON ITS OWN.
>> LOOK, FIRST, TO PUT THIS IN
CONTEXT, WE KNOW WHAT THE
OUTCOME OF THIS IS.
THEY ARE GOING THROUGH THE
HEARINGS TO GET TO IMPEACHMENT.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY DOUBT
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE IN
IMPEACHMENT.
THERE'S A LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT
WHERE THE WHISTLE-BLOWER CAME
FROM AND SO FORTH.
IN THE SAME WAY THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE WERE ANGRY WHEN BILL SAID
THAT HE WAS GOING TO LOOK AT THE
INVESTIGATION, HOW AND WHEN IT
STARTED.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T WANT US TO
LOOK AT THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
I THINK THIS IS ALL DRAMA.
I THINK IT DOESN'T MATTER.
I THINK WHAT MATTERS IS IN THE
SENATE.
AND EVEN THINK THE PRESIDENT'S
COMPLAINTS ABOUT DUE PROCESS.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
LEGAL RIGHTS.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS CAN DO
WHAT THEY WANT, BUT AT THE END
OF THE DAY, YOU ARE PLAYING TO
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC AND YOU HAVE
TO PERSUADE THEM THAT THIS IS
FAIR AND PRINCIPLED GOING
FORWARD.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE
THE CASE.
LINDSEY GRAHAM, WHEN YOU PUT
THAT RESOLUTION CONDEMNING THE
HOUSE, THAT'S GOING TO HAVE AN
EFFECT.
>> Bret: LET ME JUST TURN TO
THE FORMER U.N. AMBASSADOR TO
THE U.S., NIKKI HALEY, WHO
BRINGS UP WHAT SHE ESSENTIALLY
PAINTS AS A CONSPIRACY INSIDE
THE ADMINISTRATION WITH TWO
CABINET MEMBERS.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> INSTEAD OF SAYING THAT TO ME,
HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN SAYING THAT
TO THE PRESIDENT, NOT ASKING ME
TO JOIN THEM ON THEIR SIDEBAR
PLAN.
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN, GO TELL THE
PRESIDENT WHAT YOUR DIFFERENCES
ARE AND QUIT IF YOU DON'T LIKE
WHAT HE'S DOING, BUT TO
UNDERMINE A PRESIDENT IS REALLY
A VERY DANGEROUS THING AND IT
GOES AGAINST THE CONSTITUTION
AND IT GOES AGAINST WHAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT TO.
WAS OFFENSIVE.
THE ONE SHE'S TALKING ABOUT
FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE AND
CHIEF OF STAFF, JOHN KELLY.
KELLY RESPONDED SAYING THAT --
I GUESS THE QUESTION I HAVE,
BILL IS IF HE KNEW THAT THERE
WAS AN EFFORT TO UNDERMINE THE
PRESIDENT, WHY DIDN'T SHE SAY
ANYTHING?
STICK ABOUT THE GOOD QUESTION.
LISTENING TO HER TODAY THOUGH, I
THINK SHE'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
SHE PUT IT DOWN AND WRITTEN
WORD, SO I BELIEVE THE EMERGENCY
SAYING OUR.
SHE IS RIGHT WHEN SHE SAYS TELL
HIM NOT ME.
YOU WORK FOR HIM.
YOU DON'T WORK FOR ME.
I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT SHE'S
WORKING FOR AN ADMINISTRATION.
I DON'T THINKS SHE'S, BUT I
THINK SHE IS RIGHT ABOUT THAT
POINT.
GO TO HIM AND NOT ME.
>> Bari: I THINK SHE'S TRYING
TO MAINTAIN OPTION ANALOGY TO
RUN IN 2024.
I THINK SHE'S DOING IT IN A
BRILLIANT WAY.
SHE CAN MAKE THE ARGUMENT THAT
SHE'S NEVER BEEN A
NEVER TRUMPER.
SHE'S BEEN A SOMETIMES PROPER.
SHE'S CRITICIZED THE PRESIDENT
ABOUT SYRIA.
WHEN HE SMEARED ELIJAH CUMMINGS.
IT WAS WONDERFUL WHEN SHE SPOKE
OUT IN DEFENSE OF THE PROTESTERS
FOR DEMOCRACY IN HONG KONG.
SHE'S MAINTAINED A CRITICAL
DISTANCE.
SHE IS THROUGHOUT THIS NEEDLE IN
A WAY THAT'S BEEN PRETTY
ELEGANT.
PEOPLE THAT LOVE TRUMP SEEMED TO
LIKE HER, BUT I KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE NEVER TRUMPER WHO
WERE ALSO REALLY WARM TO
NIKKI HALEY.
>> Bret: SURE.
SHE WAS THE ONLY OFFICIAL WHO
HAD A NOBLE OFFICE SEND-OFF FROM
THE PRESIDENT.
>> I THINK IT'S INTERESTING THAT
YOU PUT IT THIS WAY.
NIKI REALLY HAS DISAGREED WITH
THE PRESIDENT ON VARIOUS ISSUES,
HARD ISSUES, HONG KONG AND SO
FORTH.
NIKKI GRAHAM HAS DONE THAT AS
WELL TOO.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, THEY ARE
UNPRINCIPLED AND THEY ARE DOING
IT JUST FOR THEIR POLITICAL --
I MEAN, MAYBE WE HAVE TO GIVE
THEM CREDIT THAT IF THEY WERE
WILLING TO SPEAK HONESTLY
BEFORE, THIS IS WHAT THEY
BELIEVE --
>> Bari: JUST ONE LAST THING
ABOUT THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
IF AN INFORMANT CALLS THE NYPD
AND SAYS, THERE'S A HOUSE FULL
OF COCAINE AT THE END OF THE
BLOCK AND THE NYPD GOES THERE
AND THEY FIND A HOUSE FULL OF
COCAINE AND THEN WE FIND OUT
THAT THE INFORMANT --
DOES IT ACTUALLY MATTER IF THE
PERSON WAS BIASED THAT THE
COCAINE WAS THERE?
I DON'T CARE --
>> Bret: I GUESS THAT IT JUST
RAISES QUESTIONS OF WHY
ADAM SCHIFF AT THE BEGINNING
WANTED TO HEAR FROM THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER, SAID HE SHOULD
BE CALLED UP, AND THEN WHEN THE
STORY COMES OUT THAT HE AND HIS
STAFF MET WITH HIM BEFOREHAND,
SUDDENLY HE IS NOT RELEVANT AT